okay everyone Avengers infinity war left
us with some big questions about the
future of the MCU and yeah spoiler
warning how will Marvel resolve half of
the universe getting snapped out of
existence when we come back for Avengers
4 well Gwyneth Paltrow who of course
plays Pepper Potts teased a possible
twist for the next movie in an interview
this week and yeah one final warning if
you don't want to know anything about
the upcoming film but this is this is
out there this is out there
okay Paltrow was asked about peppers
relationship with Tony Stark throughout
the films and she said quote she
obviously starts as this as his dutiful
assistant and then the relationship
evolves and now this decade later
they're married and they have a child
the relationship has evolved in all the
ways that great romances evolve what
Marvel Studios this is what happens when
you shoot two movies at the same time
your actors get confused I start
divulging details about the wrong movie
they forget what year it is so yes we're
looking at now it's out there let's talk
about it by a decade later Paltrow seems
to be hinting at a time jump with the
next Avengers movie taking place long
after that Oh snaps half of everyone
away and a life just has moved on they
have a kid now that's insane also be
referring to at the beginning of the
movie their hat they're getting ready to
get married and they're having the
conversation about having kids the
Morgan conversation yeah she could be
referring to that
a decade later seems specific to me and
if it's true it complicates the idea of
simply resetting or reversing Thanos's
move like any attempt to undo the snap
might undo the new lives that Tony and
the others have built in the aftermath
of this event and it presents a huge
narrative stakes for all the characters
like even if they're presented with the
way to bring down Thanos and fix
everything they might not even want to
embark on that mission at all because
maybe they're kind of but it makes it
interest it makes an interesting choice
right like do I give up this life that
I've kind of moved on with do I have to
go back what do you guys find most
interesting about I've interest for
opening with the time job that way it
was I read this earlier I thought they
she was just referred referencing the
first Iron Man movie to now I thought
that meant that it would been yeah
because also for you like think about a
10-year time jump that's how long it
took Captain Marvel the
like ditched every other major event of
course it took her 10 years to get your
good she had either other obligations or
she just didn't want to come yeah if it
does mean 10 years I don't do that don't
be don't be so mean also you guys it
took you guys 10 years to figure out
what to do next
some sons fish I also feel like if you
do the time jump yeah
you're not time jumping to like hey
everybody's happy it's like Mad Max
after half the population yeah I was
away I don't think there's like hey
we're all living normal lives but now
what it's like no there's not I don't
think there's a recovery period after it
could be like post-apocalyptic at that
point and they just have a kid because
they have something like they'd like to
do that I think kind of like gained
popularity specifically with x-men and
Age of Apocalypse and stuff like that
but they've sensed on with the Avengers
and stuff like that if somebody from an
apocalyptic future comes in so like Dana
snaps oh no gravy or tawny fireflies in
future like guys it's so much worse than
you know I'm have a kid with it is
feeling more and more x-men to me and I
feel like this is when you induce
time-travel to as a solution you do your
removal stakes it's like well what was
the point of all of that and I as much
as I love x-men like they're all over
the place with what they've been doing
the fact that they've got two different
actors playing the same character in
different what decades basically I don't
know I want it simplified I think that
this is just gonna thout road trying to
be relevant I mean trying to parse out
exactly what she says you're right she
could be referring to the decades since
the first Iron Man 2 now I just think in
context of talking about having a new
kid that's that's different like she's
not revealed to be pregnant in the movie
they're just talking about the
hypothetical to have any kids even say
she doesn't want to and man's famous
power is dream future famous it's it's
very interesting and I that's why I hope
like we talked about in past episodes
the options
with how you wouldn't dick Stannis's
decision right time travels one option
as I talked about the idea of like
jumping into a different reality Rick
and Morty's style that's why I would
hope that if they do go this way
maybe not time travel but jumping into
another reality or some other kind of
dimension or realm something that we
haven't seen over and over again movies
someone actually who watches new rocks
let me see if I can get the name correct
they they sent me this theory and at
first I was like a lot of people sent
theories and like you know it's like
it's kind of hard to like like figure
I'm all out but this one was really sad
it was from Rachel Evans there we go she
mentioned that what if the idea that
when doctor strain says this is the only
way that it doesn't mean that doctor
strains loses and he disappears it's
that everyone who's done we're seeing
we're not seeing people who are being
erased
everyone who remains is kind of like in
a limbo state and everyone who erases
know the person who lived and afteri
weirdest thing the point of view of
people who were actually already done
that's a super fascinating that was like
yeah it's already week so what's the
port of the next movie it's almost kind
of like this is actually hell you know
like we didn't make it we're the ghosts
yeah that would be super exciting to see
yeah well let us know what you make of
this is it just like gwen Paltrow miss
speaking do you think this could
actually happen if so how do you think
would be the best way to handle this so
it doesn't follow down the steps of
people who have maybe use time travel to
indulgently to fix things which i don't
think we want to see but yeah where as a
reminder subscribe to new rock stars for
all of our theories and predictions
sometimes they're right sometimes
they're wrong but they're always fun and
yeah and check out our other videos
where we talk about all the different
Avengers infinity war and future
Avengers and see you stuff thanks
everybody